how do you know when a movie is ready to
be made
so it's a great question how do you know
when a movie is ready to be made i
um i think there are always a series
a process of steps you kind of go
through right and the
part of that is your relationship as a
producer
with your director that you need
to feel that they've thought it through
fully right so it's not just the the
choices that you make
but what you're choosing not to do too
so
you have to kind of work through a
process of finding a common language
of finding what really matters like we
need this
we need beauty here we need a
transit transitional moment here we we
need to make sure the plot works it kind
of that
that construction both of the script
the the bigger meanings behind the film
the values the references
the the visual language how are you
developing those two things
in partnership right it's not just
partnership with you as the director
and the producer it's partnership
between the entire team right so
after that process of going through
development
you know i think that often in
development that language gets set
right so when you get your script ready
and you feel those moments are there
you're starting to then go out and and
prepare the you know get the cast get
the
the money in those instances but there's
a
at that point so level of surface right
that you've done
not the big deep dive once you start
bringing in your team
the dp the designer the editor the
composer the costume designer the ad
you're doing much more deeper dive
really looking at those and
prioritizing those right because you
kind of want to walk through
the the decision-making process before
you get to
set right what matters what are the
things we can't let go
once you've weighted those and
prioritize those
and you feel your team knows it i think
that ultimately and this is why you need
time
and something we've lost i think in
the crunch of making beautiful work
for less money you know as we've all had
demands to to reduce our
our budgets time is the first thing they
get sacrificed and when you sacrifice
time
you're also sacrificing serendipity
right
you're sacrificing how do we engineer
the miraculous to happen when we have
so much to do right thinking it through
i think is kind of that process of how
you go from
definition right what is it we want to
achieve to prioritization
which is ultimately managing complexity
right so how how do we
let's call it discovery to
managing complexity to engineering
serendipity
you know that process that kind of
three-step process
only once we reach that point can you
say
are we ready to shoot but the challenge
of that
is you often don't even get that luxury
right that now people are saying okay
you're ready you're ready to to make
your movie you've got your cast you got
your money
shoot in five weeks right that's all the
money you're going to get
and to to work through that
discovery prioritization management
you don't have the time so when you want
to add in that thing that lifts
what will be good work to great work
good luck you know that's that's the
part of the challenge we're living in
right now
so with the filmmakers that reach out to
you and they
ask for advice on certain things is that
one of the things that you recommend
to slow down a little bit you know
i i think this era
is one full of contradictions
right and the you know
what what is that einstein line or
someone like the sign of intelligence is
to
be able to handle two conflicting ideas
we're asked to do that all the time in
filmmaking now so
i think the logical approach for uh
artists working today is on one hand
to be incredibly prolific
ubiquitous and thus radically
collaborative
how do you have a generative life today
when sustainability is such a question
right yet because
the barriers to entry the cost of
creation
and distribution really have low
been lowered so much we have this other
uh necessity
just because we can make something
doesn't mean that we should
just because we can say something
that you want your ideas to be able to
percolate to become something that is
not just
the collective unconscious you know that
that we're all thinking about these
things
you know we all get the same inputs but
how do you get your unique perspective
on that
and time is certainly the best way to do
that
but you have to say to yourself all
right i need to build my audience
i need to connect with the community i
need to move this all forward
go go go with that same sort of uh
piece of like i need it to really stand
out there's so much
this is now the time of abundance it
means
with the bar has been lifted for
everybody we have to reach that much
higher and how are we
going to do that when we're also being
asked to be
profoundly generative when you look at a
film made nowadays
can you see the ones that did take their
time with certain things
versus the ones that rush where it's go
go go
money's on the line and and we can only
get this person at this price for this
long
it's hard it's hard to to say that
because i think that the question
of inspiration where does inspiration
comes from
you know sometimes it comes from you
just being right in the center of it you
know necessity is the mother
invention and inspiration of
other times i think it is that that
somebody has taken in a lot
contemplated and really thought how to
be additive
uh to that i'm not sure that you can say
like oh this
is the the great work they clearly had
the time
and this is the thing that just bursts
forth
um and it's not as great or maybe it's
greater like it's hard to see
sometimes energy you know
is pre-programmed and sometimes it's
just explosive
what do you see as the most crucial
chapter for your book
hope for fun ah
and why
as opposed to like identifying like a
core chapter in the book i think there's
several takeaways that i find that
come through in each chapter
the first and kind of most resonant
thing that i found
when i read the book you know proofing
it for myself
was what i say is there's no template
for
what is the proper way to direct
what is the proper way to produce what
is a proper way to collaborate
you have to approach each thing as a
custom fit how are we going to make it
work
a lot of the things that we're taught in
film schools
and so on are we observe on film sets
that we think often is given
if you subscribe to that notion it's
going to restrict your opportunities
the the most case in point i see on that
is decisiveness right we're told that we
want directors
to always lead to be the person that can
make up their mind
on the spot and say we're doing this and
some of the best directors
who've made the most beautiful movies
i've been
lucky to collaborate on aren't
particularly decisive
they're weighing the decision they're
human beings right
they're having to figure that out and i
think they might have been overlooked
if that's what somebody was looking for
in a director
right each time i think you really need
as a producer to learn how
that director wants to work right and
build your structure to allow that
sometimes they're not going to be great
on set
at deciding what to do when something
changes that's just who they are
and it doesn't mean they're not going to
give you something truly unique that has
that stamp
of individuality on it the second thing
that really resonates for me in looking
over the book is
how much chaos how much
other stuff happens on movies you know i
like to speak
i mentioned it today of producing as to
something to be managing complexity
right that that things go wrong you have
to accept it that's why this production
to deal with the
the problems but looking through my
movies
each one almost had this moment
where the movie collapsed or somebody
went crazy
or something went terribly wrong
and if i shared that with my director
or if i shared that with my financier or
my distributor
more could have happened but i as the
producer
and or the producing team you know had
to shoulder that
had to find a way to solve it get it
done
in a lot of ways in my my experience
that is almost the signature event of
the movie but sometimes
my collaborators didn't know anything
about it because
i had to shield them from yet another
problem that wasn't going to be about
telling a great story
the final thing that in
an overall that has resonated for me
today
with the book is that
it's very easy to think we're
responsible
for everything that happens to us right
that
it's our hard work or our good ideas
or our great taste that has allowed
these things to happen
and thinking it through i started to
recognize
the privilege that i've had you know
starting with being a white
middle-class male in america
that those four things
gave me entree that many people
are denied it gave me access it gave me
opportunity
i also had a lot of good fortune that
a lot of things that that i was able to
to help
build or launch partially came about
because of a scene because of a
collective
effort right because we all
wanted to go to new york at that
particular time
you know some friends have been really
generous and say wow reading your book
it's like the launching of american
independent film you were there when it
all happened
yes i was there and so was about another
150 other people who were doing
the same thing it's like oh you
discovered ang lee
yeah i discovered anglia when he walked
into my office
you discovered you know your assistants
anthony bregman great producer glenn
bassner great
film sales person yeah when they walked
into my office i discovered that
but you know and with all the directors
that i've uh
worked with they're wonderful
super talented people but they were
always diamonds
you know they're easy to spot right they
give off a glow
what they needed was somebody to you
know cut the carrots so that they really
you know were allowed to be as glorious
as they
they could be you know i think it's
really important to see
that it's always a team effort
it requires a bit of good fortune of
being in the right place at the right
time
and that there are always a series of
events
be behind what is happening at the time
right you had to get there i often
felt as a young man you know
i dropped out of college i was
incredibly dedicated and passionate
obsessed with making independent movies
which i didn't know what they were yet
they were still
you know coming into their own but at
the same time
you know i had a family that would have
taken care of me
if i ran out of money and i had to come
back home
i might have been living in a pretty
spoon to mouth
but there was a place that i could go to
i wasn't on my own i had a support
structure
you know people welcomed me when i
walked into their office
right and i was trained on
societal conventions of how to conduct
myself
i was able to do those things and that
helped a lot i was
i was fortunate so i think those
four aspects i guess are all really kind
of key
to how can you
lead a creative life i hope the final
takeaway that people have in the book
is i recognize i was i was fortunate
uh early in my career that i made a
movie that i loved
that i was told was unsellable it was a
total failure
right people looked at it and said this
film
just won't sell to anybody it's gay
it's chinese and it feels like a film
from the 1940s
except it's gay in chinese right the
film won
the berlin film festival it was angley's
second movie
the wedding banquet and my business
partner james sheamus and i
had to sell it ourselves because it had
been rejected everywhere
and we took a 700 000 film
sold it for three million dollars across
every territory in the world
at a low sales fee which returned more
money back to our investors
which made them do another film right
away with engli
and i was able to have the the clarity
of that moment
to recognize that the industry
the business was lagging behind
where the art the artists the audience
the technology was
we had all moved faster and the legacy
practices
couldn't work for what we were doing we
were able to start a sales company
based on that experience we found a it
was at that berlin film festival that i
met david lindy
who became the third partner in good
machine right built our sales company
through the work that he did and through
that model that that
we committed to we made 45 films
that we financed ourselves without
having any capital
we owned half of those movies right
i think that if you read the book and
you think about today
not just the past that it's writing
about but you start to try to say
how can i be perceptive to recognize
how that situation is occurring right
now
where the art the artist the audience
the technology has moved forward
ahead of the legacy business and market
practices of the industry
you me all of us hopefully
will start to see that this similar
opportunity
where we can build a new model that can
allow
a ambitious and diverse film culture
to not just uh be sustainable
but to also thrive that's what i hope
is the hope for film that people find in
the book
you added some personal events of your
own life in the book
anything that you weighed and you
decided you know i need to this is an
important part of telling my story i
know it's a bit personal
but i feel that other people need to
know it
in some ways both the beginning and the
end of the book
were not there originally
that that question of
recognizing the the privilege that i had
by having a family
that loved culture that loved film
that valued education that got me
exposed
and in a situation where i had
opportunity
what was something that came as i
thought through the process
it wasn't part of the original uh story
and i felt was critical to try to see
the good fortune
the privilege that that that came
i wouldn't have finished the book
frankly
if i hadn't resigned from the san
francisco film society
i'd been working on it i had tremendous
help from anthony kaufman but
i had put it aside and it was in that
break
after i resigned or really even over
the last few months of that job
that i finished the book
um and i felt that that transition
that uh design you know
the desire i had to say
filmmaking will not be my profession
right that i can do more
good not making more films
even though i think i haven't made my
best work yet
but by focusing on building a film
ecosystem
and i felt this as a mission right i
felt this in my
heart as what got me out of bed in the
morning was my drive
and i was very excited to move to san
francisco
and to work with with such a prestigious
organization
to advance film art and culture
and it was disappointing to me to kind
of see
that there were legacy practices
that were in place that wouldn't really
allow that to happen
or certainly not allow it on the
timeline that i
initially went into thinking i could do
things
so that some ways broke my heart
right and
i felt it was a necessary
conclusion to that choice of
you know what i've made 70 films
i'm at the height of my game i feel
better
about making movies than i ever have but
even still i'm going to leave the city
that i love
i'm going to move to the west coast i'm
going to take a hiatus from producing
because this is what's needed and i
think i have people who want to support
me in doing it
but it wasn't so easy so i felt like i
needed to have that chapter
to bookend it to show that process that
process
yeah and um in addition to that
start to to do the intro to the next
chapter
you know that then the decision to to
stay with the plan of trying to build
uh a workable sustainable ecosystem
for a wider diverse population of
filmmakers and
film lovers to do that
not in the nonprofit sector but to do it
through a startup
which is where i am now ted what change
or changes in the film industry would
have to happen
to get you back to producing movies
again
i'm still producing movies
and i plan to keep producing movies for
another 40 years but i'm producing
movies
now out of love out of passion
not just because i'm producing my wife's
movie i'm producing
some other films too but because i don't
want to make the compromises that come
when you
earn your living producing films
what i'm tremendously excited about what
i think is a
really phenomenon
of this year of 2014
is that i think for the first time
we as an industry as a filmmaking
community
have the capacity and the understanding
to look at what a full film ecosystem
rebuild would do when we talk about
managing complexity
i think that you can see how we've
improved the
process in filmmaking an individual
uh strategy for a film and how we
bring it to festival bring it to market
maneuver through the distribution
mechanism but we've always only been
thinking about it
on an individual basis right
and now we're able to look at all the
different
stakeholders that are throughout there
see
what their needs are to see what the
repercussions might be
the windfalls and the pitfalls might be
for them and to start to say what will
that look like
what would a rebuild of
the ecosystem look like and the core
thing there
is it's not just how to get your movie
made
it's not just about how to get your
movie made and how to get your movie
seen
it's about how to get your movie made
and compensated fairly like those are
key tenants if we want to maintain
particularly here in america our status
is
the most robust diverse film culture
and film industry in the globe we have
to say
we need to make sure that our artists
and their supporters
are compensated fairly you know that
when
somebody earns a
startup size a vc return
on their movie when someone can hold on
to their
ip and benefit from its future
iterations down the road and be able to
say look
okay those folks who that invested in
facebook
earned x times multiple
but these folks who invested in my film
or my body of work also earned
a similar multiple
i'd be happy to say that that's how i'm
going to earn my
my living again you know that that we
need the best thing that we can do
as a film culture as a film industry is
make sure
that investors earn risk appropriate
returns on their money we need to create
a sustainable investor class we need to
recognize
it's a four-legged table right it needs
all legs to stand strong
the artist the audience
the the industry and the the investors
the financial supporters
we need to look out for all side of
those to have a strong foundation
that we can build a great culture out
that will make a good meal
ted you had mentioned in a prior
interview that it's not just a great
script a great
uh you know movie idea but how does a
producer and
director know that they want to work
with each other for
two years five years six years
what are some of the things that you've
said in your mind that this
is someone that's right for me to work
with not just a great script
i i think even that question kind of
shows what a challenge collaboration is
right in that it's so easy to think
oh this person has a good track record
this person has a good script
but what you're saying is this is a
long-term
relationship where i need them to be
supportive
of me and i need to be supportive
of them and they need to be able to
recognize
what they're doing and i need them to
recognize what i'm doing
even if we don't know how we're
balancing that yet
i think there's that question of
personality and chemistry
in terms of any relationship you know
are we going to enjoy having dinner
together
over the course of these next three five
seven
years but then there's also what the
joint
project is what is it in this script or
this movie or this story world
series whatever one might be doing
what are the big ideas and can they
sustain me
will i find them as intriguing to talk
about
years down the the road
i can't look at movies as products
i can't look at movies as only
profit generators right
i look at movies as
essentially community organizers right
how people are going to come together
what are those ideas themes characters
objects of beauty you know objects of
desire
what does it encompass that's going to
keep us
you know firing on all cylinders
synapses uh across you know
the the period of working on it to
to to make a movie you need
that mix of both you know mad genius
that inspires
strong leadership that brings us forward
careful diplomacy that knows how to make
sure that each side
is represented and their needs
are surfaced and fulfilled
and ultimately friendship and joy right
you know that you that when something
moves beyond a job when it becomes
a core aspect of your life which i think
every film
is you better be receiving pleasure
from that you know whether they're new
ideas
whether they're taking you to new places
whether they're introducing you to new
people
like all those things that's the the
what
why we're so fortunate to get to make
movies but you have to be able to
appreciate that
and sometimes personalities make that
hard sometimes force of circumstance
you know financial needs makes that hard
but i think
all of those things
are what makes a good relationship work